des militaires patrouilleront bientôt
dans la nièvre
pas de présence permanente mais des
renforts ponctuels premières mises en
place dans le département le week-end
des 21 et 22 avril au moment de la fête
de la nationale 7 détachement en
question proviendra particulièrement de
dijon donc voilà il quitte
temporairement une mission sur dijon il
vient de passer quatre jours en mission
sur la dette la mission elle est
clairement de la lutte antiterroriste à
nous ne faisons pas n'entendez pas de
mission de police et de maintien de
l'ordre
la présence des forces de l'opération
sentinelle sera un appui aux effectifs
de police et gendarmerie
la demande a été faite par la préfecture
une précaution notamment après les
attentats de carcassonne et trèbes
ils sont présents sur les grands
événements et puis comme istres ans sur
le territoire pendant quelques jours et
nous appuierons aussi sur donc la
présence dynamique dans les centres
commerciaux au sein au centre-ville de
nevers les événements de carcassonne a
apporté la preuve s'il en était besoin
que la menace est partout et que dans
tous les territoires doivent être en
situation dont de protéger la population
le dispositif sera réservé à quelques
événements de grande ampleur dans les
prochains mois la fête de la loire fin
mai où les masters de pétanque en août
en bénéficieront pour autant les
nivernais sont partagés sur le besoin et
l'impact d'une telle présence militaire
n'enlèvera pas tous les risques mais
effectivement ça peut rassurer la
population
ça peut être n'importe où à mon avis
maintenant ce symbolique c'est que
symbolique
je pense qu'il y aura pas de risque
j'aimerais cirque comme ça les effectifs
dépêché dans la nièvre sont pour le
moment tenu secret mais la présence sera
visible d'après la préfecture
en france dix mille militaires sont
engagés depuis janvier 2015 dans
l'opération sentinelles